this is a production of cornell
university
hi everyone i hope you are all doing
good my name
kenhu i'm a research associate from dr
lily's lab
today i will talk about the green
function
of orange protein in coordinated
regulation of photosynthetic payments
so our level is interested in
phytonutrients including
including carotenoids and flavonoids
if you go to wegmans sometimes you will
find
very beautiful cauliflowers with
different color varieties
like orange cauliflower purple
cauliflower and a green cauliflower
we characterized the orange gin for
orange cauliflower the
purple gin for purple cauliflower and
currently we are working on the green
gin for green cauliflower
today i will mainly talk about the
orange gene with
and its new green function the orange
gene controlling
beta-carotene accumulation in carotenoid
accumulation was first characterized in
dr lily's lab
in cauliflower it's a transportable
insertion uh caused
different splicing or origin after that
a golden snip in origin was also
identified
in melon which is a caused amino acid
substitution of
rng protein caused carotenoid
accumulation in melon
then we identified the functions
of our variants in chromoplasta
formation
carotenoid accumulation and recently for
the chromoplast
division which is orange functions of
our variants in recent years we also
find that our y type
with their div with a different
localization in nucleus
or y type function in chloroplast
development
and recently we have some preliminary
results showed that
or function in photosynthetic pigment
the biosynthesis which
is the green which are the green
functions of
orange gene
for the orange function i'll briefly
talk about that
both in cauliflower and in melon or can
induce
chromoplastic formation and carotenoid
accumulation however
we find that the chromoplasta number is
only
one or two large chromoplasts in each
cell
compared to a lot of carbon plaster in
tomato
so why or induce the chromoplastic
division uh
do complex information but also repress
the composite division in cauliflower
and melon
until recently we got the answer
we find that the mutant version of our
or his
can bind the ox3 which is an important
factor for
chloroplast division this interaction
affected the binding between ax3 and pr6
which finally affected the chromoplast
division
so we got an answer of why our his
affected plastic division
or is important for cartoon accumulation
and
plant nutrient nutrition improvement
it's important for breeding it's not
only
for the orange color of cauliflower
for the male fruit and recently origin
find associated with character
carotenoid accumulation
at major qtls in sweet potato and
carrot actually it is also a
it is a also a great uh
uh candidate gene to uh and engineer
crops
like potato tomato and rice in
particular over extraction of oil can
increase
carotenoid the accumulation in plato
tubes in tomato
over expression or his protein can
induce
chromoplast formation at the very early
stage of tomato fruits
in rice together with our overexpression
of biosynthetic enzymes of carotenoids
or can increase the accumulation of
carotenoids
then recently we find the nuclear
nuclear
localization and its function in
chloroplast development
actually the nuclear localization of or
has been
discovered for years including the
cauliflower or the nuclear localization
of cauliflower or
the nuclear localization of araptosis or
and the nuclear localization of sweet
potato ore
however the biological significance
of the nuclear localization of this
orange protein is
still unknown until recently
we find that all our potential dynamic
localization during cadillac and
greening process
we find the dual localization of our gfp
in both
nucleus and chloroplasts the greening
process or called detolation process is
very
is the most important process after
plant seed germination
the plant thinning undergoes significant
changes
from dark to light growing including the
colitis start to open
the chloroplasts begin to development
the membrane structure inside the
chloroplasts
begin to reformation the photosynthetic
protein complex begin to assembling and
the photosynthetic pigments
start to accumulation during this
process
plants need to go through this process
smoothly this process shouldn't be too
fast or not too slow
otherwise the young plant ceiling will
be damaged
we find that the overexpression of or
the nuclear accumulation of or protein
can negatively affect the cotyledon
greening process
the over-expression of or protein causes
delayed
greening or detolation process or
autopsies seedling catalytion
then we're trying to figure out the
mechanism of this
phenomenon we find that uh or indexed
with a tcp transcription factor
in the nucleus we identified the or and
the tcp p14 interaction by
e2 hybrid and we confirmed the
interaction
by co-immuno precipitation we can we
find that
their induction happened in nucleus by
biofact sa
then we find that the overexpression of
or
will repress the early light-induced
protein expression during the isolation
process
early light-induced proteins play a very
important role in photo protection by
binding
both chlorophylls and character noise
during the detolation process
so how that r regulated those early
light induced early light induced
protein expression we find that tcp
transmission factor can
directly bind the promoter of early
light induced proteins
by luciferase reporter essay and
by our chromatin ipsa we find that
the or association with the ellip one is
to promoters through the tcp transcript
tcp 14 transcription factor
interestingly we also find that tcp
interest field factor can directly
activate origin expression
by a reporter essay we also
tested the gene expression of or in
tcp-40 mutant
and a tcp-14 over-expression line we
find that
in tcp-14 mutant the oral expression
is significantly reduced while in the
overexpression line of tcp 14
the origin expression is significantly
upregulated
so these results suggest that origin
expression is also regulated
by tcp 14 transcription factor
so let's go back to the deterioration
process during
the dilation process we isolated the
nucleus fraction and
plastic fraction we find that the
nuclear or protein level decreases
during deteriolation process while the
transparent factor tcp 14 protein level
increases during the detolation process
while the for the plastid or protein
accumulates in chloroplasts
so finally we conclude that during the
detolation process the ortcp14
together regulated this process makes
the process not too fast not too slow
the nuclear or function as a break over
the detolation process by repressing
the tcp 14 transcribing factor activity
while tcp 14 is a
accelerator of the utilization process
by activating early light-induced
proteins expression
as well as activating o-arginine
expression
after light illumination the or protein
level reduced in nucleus while the
tcp-14 level in nuclear start to
accumulate
which finally induce chloroplast
deformation for photosynthesis
talking about chloroplast recently we
have some preliminary results showed
that or blood
could play a critical role in the
coordination
of both photosynthetic pigment synthesis
including chlorophyll and carotenoids
properly is the largest synthetic
process on earth
this animation showed that the plant
land plant
fluorescents with seasonal change
of course those crops like uh soybean
cones they contribute a large part of
land and fluorescence uh in this
animation
so uh what causes those land plant
florence sense
and why they are important for
photosynthesis and
plants of course chlorophylls and
carotenoids
those are photosynthetic pigments
can cause the plantar fluorescence
chloroplast is the main site for
photosynthesis
and cholophil and keratinoids play
important
role in light harvesting and converting
light energy
for plants
so the right amount recommendation of
photosynthetic
photosynthetic pigments are very
important for plants because
plants undergo different environmental
changes like the seasonal change
the temperature change the water change
uh those photos i took
i took a uh around bb lake
i still remember the good times when i
attended a seminar and i take a shot to
walk around the bibi lake and i
took a beautiful photos we can clearly
see that the amount
and the composition of catenoids and
colorfuls
changed during the seasons
so how are these pigments coordinately
regulated
both chlorophyll and carotenoids are
synthesized inside
chloroplasts a mechanism collectors is
the first
committed step for chlorophyll
biosynthesis
using protoprofane mine and substrate
magnesium killer tests are consisted of
four different accepted four different
subunits
chl i chl d c h r h also known as gum
5 and a gun 4 subunit while phyton
synthesis
psy is the first committed step of
carotenoid biosynthesis using ggpp
as substrate
previously we identified that
chloroplast or is the key regulator of
keratinoidal biosensors
or together with clip practice controls
the steady level
protein level of psy in green leaves so
how does chloroplast
or function in photosynthetic process
we take a look at the or overexpression
line and
or mutant or or like that mutant in our
arabidopsis we find that or or
like double mutants should repel green
phenotype and the photosynthetic ability
of
or mutant are also reduced so we are
wondering
could it just be the result of reduced
carotenoid content because we already
established
the model that are regulated the com
first committed step of cardinality
biosynthesis
by stabilizing psy protein level
then we take a closer look of the
chloroplast
or double mutant we find that the
silicoid membrane
in or mutant or or like the mutant is
missing so we couldn't we couldn't find
any granule
uh cell chord cell chord in
orange mutants
the granulocytic cyclones are uh
rich of light half string complexes and
photosystem ii uh when we run blue
native geo
we find that in oro like double mutant
the chlorophyll contender in many
chloroplast complexes are significantly
reduced
especially for the light harvesting
complex 2 assembly
for the photosystem 2 complexes and
the higher super complex of photosystems
so this blue network clearly shows that
chlorophylls and
as well as the lighthousing complex
assembly is significantly reduced
in or or like double mutant
then when we first run the second
dimension of this blue network geo
and to the western plot of all the
subunits of
lighthousing complex we find that
the less pigments affect the
lighthousing complex assembling
especially the lighthearted complex
proteins b1b2
they are less assembled in lighthearted
complex assembly
so why what causes a chlorophyll
reduction in or that or or like double
mutant
um we you we used several chlorophyll
biosynthetic pathway mutants
and checked the glory of biosynthetic
intermediate accumulation mechanism
protocol friendly and protoperforini
we can visualize those intermediate
accumulation by
laminar scan under laser convocal
microscope because they have a
specific emission peaks
we find that or like w mutants use a
similar
protoprofe9 accumulation like
gun for mutant and chri mutant which is
the subunit of first committed step of
protoperforin 9
mechanism kelly tells
to convert the proto49 to mechanism for
the perforating line
then we uh test the interaction bit
interaction between or and biosynthetic
enzymes over chlorophyll chlorophyll
biosynthetic pathway
we find that or directly interact with
the mechanism collected
subunit i chli but not other subunits
we also confirmed this induction by
bifect assay
so what's the role of our plane in this
interaction since oil is a molecular
chamber
we perform the reforming essay using
different
domains our entertainment domain and our
c terminal domain
and to incubate it with either just tag
the chli
and his tag chli
we find that only intermittent domain
can increase the soluble fraction of
chli no matter attack with gst or his
type
so this results suggest that or can
prevent
chli protein aggregation
then we checked the in vivo evidence
we used chx to inhibit the new protein
synthesis
and test the protein stability
after chx treatment we find that in oro
like double mutant
the stability of chli is significantly
reduced
while other enzymes for chlorophyll
biosensors like
crd1 and mpo b their stability not a
significant affected you know r or like
double mutant
the core unit d1 or photosynthesis 2 is
not affected
the light hypothesis complex b1 b2 and
b3
although their protein levels lower are
lower
in r or like double mutant compared to y
type
however their stability is also not
affected by
or or like double mutant so we conclude
that
or is essential for chli protein
stability in vivo
so taken together with our previous
results
we conclude that or is a master
post-transcriptional regulator
coordinated layer regulator both
photosynthetic pigments chlorophyll
and carotenoid biosensors for
photosynthesis and chloroplast function
more specifically more specifically or
can stabilize
the first committed step of chlorophyll
biosynthesis
by stabilizing chli protein and also
stabilize the first
committed step of carotenoid
biosynthesis
synthesis by stabilizing phytoin
synthesis
as we previously reported this
mechanism provide a potential
method for plants better survive under
antibiotic stress
including live stress heat stress drug
stress and so on
currently we are still working on this
project
when we take a look at rna-seq data we
find that
the oil expression showed a big
fluctuation under certain antibiotic
stress
including heat stress drug stress and
wounding stress
we also tested the or expression after
heat treatment
at 37 degree we find that the expression
of
or is induced by heat stress
we also tested the overexpression of our
plants
we find using csx treatment and
heat stress treatment we find that the
over expression of or
increases the choi protein stability and
psy protein stability
under heat stress so over expression of
work
increase the stability of both
colloquial
biosensors and carotenoid biosynthesis
enzymes
under heat stress
then we check the phenotype of our
double mutant and overexpression
we find that even or like double mutants
shield
less colloquial under normal growth
condition the plant grows or
more specifically the plant size and not
significantly
reduced compared to wild type however
after heat treatment
we find that the plant growth is
significantly
repressed compared to wild type while
the overexpression line of our shield
better grows
under heat stress condition
so our our preliminary results showed
that
oil is important for plant resistance to
abiotic stress especially for
heat stress then we are wondering
is our level correlated with the fitness
of
different natural vibrations in this
case we are using our aerodynamics
uh we select selected uh several
uh our dossier natural vibrations with a
low
expression low or expression and high or
expression
the lower expression level uh
reversible natural vibrations vancouver
zero
it is reported less resistant to drought
while both vancouver 0 and cvi
they should should prefer to code
condition
while the high level or expression
vibration
and e1 which is reported more resistant
to draw stress
we are still trying to figure out that
uh or is really correlated with the
fitness of
the doses of natural vibrations
actually oil is a very conserved gene in
green algae and land plants
so based on our results we concluded
that as a conservative gene or can be a
useful tool
to elevate photosynthetic potential in
crops
and viral variable environmental
conditions
in addition to the
existing role of our in enhancing
carotenoid production and accumulation
for better nutrition
so this work is performed in dr lily's
group sensor for our
great group of members and our excellent
undergraduate students
magna and lauren thank you for our
collaborators dr shandu
from nanjing university and michael
medler from planet
breeding and genetics thank you our
collaborator
casey austin young from michigan state
uni
michigan state university and
her postdoc attention in help with our
chrome plastic division project this
project is supported by usda
nifa grant and usdirs based funding
so thank you for your attention and i'd
like to take your questions
thank you
hi this is adrian i'd like to ask
when you have or coordinating both the
stability of the chlorophyll
and the carotenoid biosynthesis
how does it coordinate them equally or
how do you then get
the right balance between chlorophyll
and carotenoids
yeah that's a great question um so we
find that
or can increase both the stability of
two enzymes of psy and chl
cli
we are measuring the enzyme activity of
this enzyme after different conditions
to figure out that
to quantify quantify that how or affect
those uh and both and or both the global
and carotenoid
synthesis activities so
currently we only have the uh
only have the currently we don't have
the quantification result but we're
still working on that
thank you that's a great question thanks
so any additional questions
so um doctor jim
asked how does or differ among our
doctor's
sessions um from
our results we checked that it's roughly
about uh
two or three fold among the highest
lowest ones
but we are still want to check the uh
protein level that's just a
transcription level we're going to check
the protein level of those
natural vibrations or different
accessions so careful can you read
the question yeah um
in most plants there are two copies
two cups not too not two cups uh
they are or and or like in most species
but
in some species they are more than
because the
genome duplication in
green algae there is only a single copy
in all the green algae
so it's a highly conserved gene
in land plants and green algae
well so if
there are no more questions please
join me to thank our speaker
thank you all thank you
thank you for listening
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu